I'm speaking to mr.
Norman. Count kind who worked on the sydney
harbour bridge workshops at milton's
point. And i'm asking first when you promised
wake up in sydney where bratton said
paddington you know and what were the
circumstances. You knew were going days what
was your and your father and mother. Well
i was left most of the my mother looked
after me. Mostly my father went
down and what did he do for
a living. Well he was in the
furnishing business and when then on
a soldier and from then on we got right out
of touch. And what was it. We do go to
school. Well several because
graphically we moved around
a bit but my last girl was camp and grammar
school that was situated at narelle and
. And earlier i went to the first girl
i went to i think was one public. And
a couple of others in between. I we went
to adelaide at one stage and i went to
a college. There was
it was actually it was
a salvation army. Run place and
it was all right. You know
fair but
a bit hard for me what subjects did
you like best subject i was ballin
. And i like to listen to history
but you know i can memorize it
and become good at it you know you're
required to memorize dates in those days.
Yeah that was
a big problem. What was your first job
and the chemist shop and william street
sydney. It's
a park and i think what you know
not so very long and then i. My
mother was steward us at that time. And
she'd arranged with these people for me to
be apprenticed to plastering in wellington
new zealand. So i went over on the
element hour and i was there for about
a while but two years. Did you
like that. I enjoyed it because
i was young enough it was
a sort of an adventure but i was away from
everybody i knew and but i got in with
some nice people named newman and i was
a sort of extra boy. They had two sons. And
when you didn't get any more schooling
after that. Now you know i passed the
intermediate at camera grammar school
and that was the finish of the schooling
yes. And from there. Your father he was
away at the war during that time was
a. Yes. Well he was from boy
until eighteen or nineteen and
then he went around the country quite
a lot. So how old were you then.
Well i can't have anybody left from
double by pay that's
a visit. Kind of member really
i'm guessing about eight
something like that. Do you remember him
going away particularly well i remember
seeing him on the tram and when he went
away. You know me. What's about to
shellings i think you're going to shellings
in my hand when he got on the fam. But
i stuck him several times
after that but he wasn't
a father as far as you know he was
a list and most gentle and
when the man but he drank.
And of course he used to turn up at all
sorts of places but there never will.
This is
a hand to me and there was he also got
to your mother in that sense. Yes. Yeah
kind of thing but unreliable.
I'm getting a bit. I have
a spell. So how did you come
to be working on the sydney
harbour bridge. Well that we were
living in forbes street darlinghurst
in a sort of a flat type of
thing and it was owned by
a fellow named jimmy chilvers
who was the foreman of the
he was a sort of
a panic and buy us some foreman where
i was working on the cranes and i
couldn't get
a job mother was quite ill and
she couldn't work anymore so.
Here and for me to go down there. The age
part of it. Well i was about the same
size as i am now so i passed. All those
strange then up one of the chaps at work
down there a fellow name said lowe is
a pretty bright bloke. He said i knew you
weren't twenty one because he said you
didn't talk like a twenty one year
old he said there was yes it talk
a bit silly here. So but i did i
got full money and £5 fifteen
a week. I think it was. And i
lasted until such time as i became
a dance and it was that chilvers
that wasn't he. Clayton killed
was killed. Yes and his brother says
his son. Cecil was also working there.
Do you remember the circumstances of his
being killed in power. It happened after i
was. Put off but i did hear that they was
taking
a left with us. And i say i'm the punts
to put some timber and i need to get the
change and there was a bit of
a wash and i slept. I came down here when
the teen and i believe both his neck and
knocked him back into the water and said
that that tallies with what i've already
heard and seen in the in the hopes
of the inquest. Yes. Yeah well i
just heard it. You know secondhand
because i was off quite
a while when you working there. What
was the job like well i liked it. It
was really exciting type of thing in
many ways. At times i've got buying
you know you know all sorts of pieces of
the whole you know all marked and we had
to unload them and then sort them
in the stacks. And let them from
overseas ships mostly the
piano used to come in
a lot and some down the power pass it
. Came from newcastle. It was quite
small and it used to being longer lines
eight sign. And was it dangerous. Joe
a couple of times or several times. Yes
but dangerous. What size were the plates.
Well some of those plates. Would be
forty feet and about six feet wide.
Sometimes they used to
buckle over and i always had
a tail on them to stop them
from slipping so. And the wind
was often very difficult because of just
a feeling on us we have to grab
the end of the day here and then
run the crane on and then down there
with the angles any any easier or where
they'd gone so very very dangerous because
i couldn't string them powell out of
a ship's hold so they had a saying
a month and then. Well to do that
they had to put timber all round to
give the chain or turn
a bit of paper and one day. I was going
up in my job to grab the tail of
it and put on the. Waste and put
. Timbers down there so it would be able
to get time done to lift them over to the
gantry. And just as i went to grab
it. I heard that noise to say
some of them. I think how. And i
realised it was temping so so i mean
i was the one that was going in there and
i think we have to make him want me. So i
went up there then back to want to move
point and i heard the clatter and i mean i
look. When i got far enough away i mean
one of them. It's mean by that much like
time on again. But when it's best to
inform or planks and also mouthful and
just take about two inches wide and they're
just like i don't standing up and the
other fall now one nearly hit me
and i think that was one bad one
and not
a bad one was when one
mirth in its hip and the
cause of bulk and as
a bouquet make ice and then falling fifty
yards. Tried at me and you know while i
wire snapped control it
can happen. But you know
once in him that i knew who was any and
i have this can be something right.
You know. Julie said that i said i've been
a dancer he said i never seen anybody so
good on their feet but i had to because it
was coming straight out my father turned
round. I would have seen which way it was
coming. Anyway i got by and from that
one and the other dangerous occasion
. Was his angle arms and twelve
by twelve one very long and i was
having a bit of
a sticky riding on the gantry crane while
the other fellows from bring these down
and i got the same noise. They'd been
slowing uneven and i saw them coming out
towards me so i jumped off. And i make
a cup that deep into the air into the
bottom of the gantry crane and slither down
onto the whirlpool over the place i was
a bit fortunate on that occasion that i had
good hearing and i heard it was time to
get out there on the other front trying
time i tell you man. This i was riding on
our cry and we weren't supposed to and i
was rolling on the hooks and said loud was
my cry and driver. He swung right out
over the harbor and then he threw it into
free rock and hear my going down then in
don't mean that all the right up to about
here. I tell you that felt really horrible
because i didn't know just when the
train was swimming but simply something
laughing instead of and i got pretty weapon
temporary scare you know. And that's
that's in lots of other cases. You know.
But. We were going to i think two
shillings of me gets me because i'm the
responsibility of travelling and we're
supposed to ride on the lanes but we often.
We often just stand in the balance place.
All the plates were quite long and so was
quite a few certain shapes you
know and we used to often
a couple of clips each side and stand
on that amount of hold the middle was
a lot of the. The steel knocked about that
it had to be straightened and yes yes.
Those plates are telling about there was
a big well set up at the end. But still
a stored there in there and they just go
into the light family vacation shop and as
me well and then straight and all that.
Do you remember who worked at machine the
mangles well they are if i remember
once drove him look i'm sky he was
a happy guy. If you made
a fire that cricket and football
women play in the houses. He's down
a name i can remember from that. Well you
don't remember the yank you know the
mayor in fact i thought it was i know where
these are if you're not and we called
him scruffy. There was
a fellow and spoke for the door all and
i thought you know and i told me he was
high and there was somebody around the
place that often people called again they
reckon he worked on the mangle so i
don't know. You know. So many different
counties and nationalities down there
was about the angle straight and i
did you see that you know now i live. I
get an idea. In the back of my head about
it but i just can't remember them. I have
a photograph but no names no. What up
the other end there was the was the
plate. What they call it the plane. Each
plane that was that was that near you
where you were working. Didn't say that
working and what about the guillotine that
was to make
a lot of noise. Yes yes i remember the
guillotine. You know very noisy was it came
down and down
a plane. And had to be pretty heavy to cut
through some of this stuff there when
the famous rifle was a bell
about two crap. But yes
a playground lanka like that fell i
mentioned up there. I walked under
a ladder one day i raced home for lunch
because i only just lived above. The time
and i won thirteen thirteen shillings barbers
recall and so i walked under the sun
later the next day and that and
a bit more so. Walking under
a ladder didn't mean that much do you
remember the bloke we do used to run the
crowd americans. I don't know frenchy now
and i don't remember the name and i never
played that much. I got cured i got cured
after those two episodes so it was right
inside. And most of us when we had our
lunch. We'd sit outside cry and i was
a come down. We happened but we happy you
know and then i used to go home now and
then i had to quit because i met up some
steps we lived in alford street right
opposite where my bowling club is now. Do
you remember the some of the boys going
swimming down there. That happened
a few times but not very much. I know we.
Everybody was down there months catching
mackerel there was found thousands
of them. Do you remember
any other events particularly around their
own drummer seeing anything around the
harbour of note you know
i might have to think
a little bit about that i saw plenty i was
the official reader of the ships that
came in an hour because i had good eyes in
those days getting away from the harbour
part of it. I do remember we
went on strike and marched in
and sacco and vanzetti were two i w
w workers in america and
we thought that was
a great adventure the young fellows. You
know to me but since i've thought of it.
It's incredibly stupid to do such
a thing like that when it was so far away
but we're more and centre the donald
grant was at the head of the prince
procession that time as riordan reardon was
a union rep down there very
posing man. And workers
union. Yes it could have us features but
he could he could hold on the audience. He
was
a blacksmith just up from where i worked.
Actually he faced where the way the. I forget
the name of the launch and. To go backwards
and forwards to from those trying to
you know. And that was go out the launch
and up they were to back to stop answering
it and resent it and he was chairman of
the shop committee was yes he was able to
it's
a must. Down there but he wasn't he wasn't
in the ironworkers you know he was in
the blacksmith's so i think he was
chairman of the shop committee. Yes that's
probably what it was yeah yeah you know i
didn't go into it that it's that in those
days but when i talk about taste and
everything else like that. Well i've got
a scene. Do you remember the secretary of
the un workers union colin tanner telling
colin ten. Yes oh yes he was around for
a long time it was george doc file. Page
intakes and everything. I don't know
it was from. I don't know scotland
but yeah yeah. Oh yes i remember
him well i don't know whether. But i thought
to say that him i think there might
have been no there was
a communist in between him and lied
to it after that. You member any
other union meetings you member your member
being meeting being chaired by arthur
riordan anyway and the only one
i really remembered was the one
that when they decided on the second renzetti
stop work type of thing to have to go
on the much. But beyond that i didn't
attend any talk now do you know you know
there was much union disputation you know
i don't remember much at all. Really.
No one incident i can think about.
Jimmy devereaux he used to be
a champion footballer and
he worked inside and so on.
Way way line put the fabricated stuff put
it in the heavy shop to be finished off.
It simply was putting less than we all
just have to go in and help them down and
they had a deck of those plates
telling about their high and i have
a line came like that. Jimmy god damn jimmy
tween that i think you asked i think i
tell. Toby ill for
a long time but he and i then
do you remember any plates
being that were already drilled coming
through off the ships that were you know
ready to now and i don't
remember any coming off. Now now
. Practically everything that came off
on our crane. We used to have to have
a scraper to get the id numbers on
them clear that show. I think was
it. Rusty very little i never
saw much stress it all
a coating of very sticky stuff but
i don't remember much rest at all.
So it was
a sticky stuff you were cleaning off not
rusty just just to look at the at the
number so that the stock takers could
identify it and do you remember any
as a ute. Did you unload the bearings.
I had laid out a lot of bearings and
a lot of things we unloaded all the
cables they were in coils of eight and
a half ton and i could remember they had
two hundred and sixteen strands and they
were the ones that held the arts in
suspension of the the bit the bearing
. Marines came in parts they would be
already drilled wouldnt they. Oh you're
talking about the big berries at the base
of the parlance. Well i don't remember i
don't remember whether we took them
off. I think they might have been
a bit too heavy for our crane. So the
bearings that you were dealing with would be
deliberately for the for the approach
spans. Well yes i mean they wouldn't be. I
don't think they'd be big enough and you
know i don't know what part of the bridge
. They went on but i don't think they've
been big enough. So there was lots of
stuff in. Inwood all also
that we unloaded to you see i
had. Everybody that worked in the workshops
reckoned that they did all the work of
drilling and processing all the steel.
Whereas the some people in middlesbrough
reckoned that they spent years drilling
repetition pieces and i just trying to
absorb stablish whether the repetition
pieces were in fact used in the bridge or
whether they were some other job. Well i
believe some other job because i don't
recollect any any drill stuff coming
out at all. And i remembered it was
a set up was right through the light shop
there. And as a matter fact one chap had
a nasty accident there i believe he slept
as he pulled the drill down and it got
him down the bottom of the some of our
shells timely that he lost one testicle over
that. Yeah well that was
seven hours you know he was
a dog man on the gantry cranes and you know
as you mentioned you know marley that's
just struck a chord now. Yeah.
Yes he is he was very fortunate
a horrible damn thing to happen. And
apparently he was. Well he managed to father
my children up to its
head was good. It was
a rough ride one. Yeah. Is
it was i believe there was
a number of accidents so what do
you do you hear of an accident to
a swede by the name of peterson. No i
don't remember that one. I remember
one on the other side of the bridge. You
know these that all train type things that
run on a chain. You can my man can lift
a fair way for them to change. Yeah well
this fellow i think he finally fell on the
other side on the southern side. We only
heard about it. They finally came down to
the end of the chain turned up again and
he lost his grip and fell and then it was
much you and mature it
was and then there was
a fellow named kelly i think that lived was
it. Kelly that. Is vic kelly that was i
didn't know him because most of those fellows
were up on that on the bridge itself
. You know he was
a point to make it. He fell in the water
off the deck and he survived he came back
to work a couple of weeks later
a couple of weeks but they came early
got was. I think two broken ribs.
Yeah. Goodness incredible
. I. I don't know i know their
names i can know i remember the
names of the fellers that worked out there
with me there. My driver crying driver
was said loud and my offsider i had to was
name sanderson he was from middlesbrough
. And the other one was a fellow
named johnny musher he was
a french-canadian and i think
a brother in law. Jimmy chilvers. I never
ever sure about that but he taught me
quite
a lot about the rigging business because
he he sailed before the mast. You know
before he came and settled in australia.
So he he did some things that thrives
and things and things like that. I never
even seen you know. So he helped me out in
that particular part of it although i would
still be hands on on the business. He
was
a leading player by and because i
started before him and there was jack
welch it was the other trying to over.
He was from england and eric wilson was
against a crane driver and he was
a football packed wilson. Here's the thing
he had in hand up to its face like that
and how the event and then saying
he would tell you did you was
this lunch stuff or was it up the pub it
hydrocarbon the turnouts you know. We're
just to have football turned out and
things like that. We used to train up at
university park and phil and
i'm vince it was the captain
and then since i was
a top cricket it was this rugby
league was it or yeah. Oh yes we
had been back guernsey same as north because
it was this time when low grade normal
. And i was tooth very started
the fire brigades and
almost i can't remember any more and
mascaras by in places like that that i
did that i believe
a figure was in use and try and kind and
why i think. Everything else like that.
Richard dislocation. But i went back to
work too soon. That just came back again.
But then that my head was
there any other sort of
well i mean the power from the football and
the outings with the football was there
any other social things. You know not really
remember who was there as people care
over there you know i don't in those days
i don't think i used to bet on horses.
You learn your lesson with the crowd
america but i suppose so. But no i didn't
really take to horse racing and
in the early days you know. But i
can't remember the osprey book at all in
a way he would have been betting in
sixpences and and or exact and then as
a society. Finally amalfi still alive
an over interview to be less he
married one of the waterhouse ladies who
had run the pub up here. Yeah it was like
they had the pub on the way down to where
lerner park entrance is now that the
imperialism. Or you'd have to ask the
locals for that i can't remember.
We used to go over to circular
quay when we knocked off there was
a race to jump off the ferries
it was a key part two and
a cuttable i can remember and i was one
of those they are ringing in the still on
the rail and jumped onto the wharf. Has
to be first out through the turnstile
stupid when you come to
take me i can look back
a bit because i tell you what i was
fairly athletic and i said jump
a long way to be first
of no prizes. No prizes.
Do you remember the names of the people
who were brought up from england for the
doorman longs to remember any
of them. I can remember quite
a few there was henry and our
martin brothers and had some sort
of
a turnout i can't remember just what the
kasian was but he was. Addressing quite
a few of us and he said as soon as this
bridge is finished. They should start
constructing another one because this one
will be i think the word was inadequate
in
a very short time and of course that's been
proved very right. I can remember. A fellow
named patterson who was
a scot and he was one of the best spoken
men i've ever listened to. He has
to bring people. I think it was the architect
used to bring people around and we
could hear me explaining this and the other
thing to all these people and it was
a joy to listen to him talk.
You know and i think there was
a little field who i think was
a department by roads and folks he seemed
to carry on afterwards. He was public
works during the but he was inspector
he was actually his title was resident
engineer for the public works department
and that's why we saw so much of him and i
thought he must have been because he went
to say the god of the dam later. Yes but
of course the public bridge department was
finished with the bridge and there was
an arrangement made to transfer some of
the engineers or most of the engineers to
to the main roads. I mean
actual fact there was
a deal between bradfield and the new
all of the of the main roads board. To
take the men and that's how they got the
bridge to do you mark got the bridge
rather than the railways. I
say so. Yes and there was
among those of course rest of ennis
a big. Very bulky man and he was
a kingpin i was there the day that i joined
up the medevac we all got to canberra
flown which i spent and he said keeping
for all these years and i think they
actually knocked us off its three o'clock
that day the day the bridge was it but it
was fascinating. Just to watch that business
take place because we could almost see
the bridge doing that you know and then of
course the great cheer that went up and
. Terry's total goodness knows
what not a great. It was
a great day. Really not my respect because
when i was there it hurried up my
getting put up. Well i lasted long and now
because i swung the decking probably i
chaffed and then. It was our
mother a me double t i t he was
a former he was
a two mill middles were banned i
think and what he looked like. Well
now i can see him you know very it would.
It wouldn't be any bigger than me. He had
a big pinky type takes pale
eyes and not fair here.